En este video, me ven con un traje reflectivo
y nuestro sistema de cámaras escanea la pared
a un ritmo de cuatro veces por segundo.
El traje es reflectivo
así que podemos capturar los fotones necesarios
para determinar dónde estoy y qué estoy haciendo
sin que la cámara me enfoque de forma directa.
Al capturar los fotones que se dispersan desde la pared hacia mi traje,
de regreso a la pared y nuevamente hacia la cámara,
podemos capturar este video "indirecto" en tiempo real.
Creemos que este tipo de escaneo no lineal
puede ser útil en distintas aplicaciones: en los vehículos autónomos
pero también en las bioimágenes,
donde necesitamos ver el interior de las estructuras diminutas del cuerpo.
Quizá podríamos equipar con sistemas de cámaras similares a los robots
que enviamos a explorar otros planetas.
Tal vez ya escucharon sobre cómo mirar detrás de las esquinas,
pero lo que les mostré hoy habría sido imposible hace dos años.
Por ejemplo, podemos escanear enormes escenas ocultas en el exterior
en tiempo real,
y hemos avanzado bastante en conseguir que esta tecnología
pueda efectivamente detectar un automóvil en el futuro.
Pero por supuesto, aún hay desafíos que superar.
Por ejemplo, ¿podemos escanear escenas ocultas a larga distancia,
en cuyo caso se recolectan muy pocos fotones,
con láseres que usen poca energía y sean seguros para la vista?
¿Podemos crear imágenes a partir de los fotones
que se han dispersado muchas más veces que un único rebote detrás de la esquina?
¿Podemos tomar nuestro prototipo que es, pues, actualmente muy grande
y reducir su tamaño a algo que sea útil para las bioimágenes,
o para un tipo de sistema mejorado de seguridad para el hogar?
¿Podemos darle a esta nueva modalidad de escaneo de imágenes otras aplicaciones?
Es una tecnología nueva emocionante
y podría haber otras aplicaciones que no hemos ni imaginado aún.
Así que... un futuro en el que haya vehículos autónomos
puede ahora parecernos distante, pero estamos desarrollando las tecnologías
que podrían hacer que los autos sean más seguros e inteligentes.
Con el acelerado ritmo de los descubrimientos científicos
y las innovaciones,
nunca se sabe qué nuevas y emocionantes aplicaciones
podríamos encontrar tras doblar la esquina.
(Aplausos)